[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
nitri Serien schönen Samstagabend
zusammen für den Sport mit mir im Studio
ist Katja Stresow guten Abend und wir
blicken jetzt auf die Themen an diesem
Samstag
zurück unter ukrainischer Flagge nach
heftigen Kämpfen gibt Russland die
strategisch wichtige Stadt Liman in der
Ostukraine auf
mehr Geld in der Krise ab heute gilt der
neue Mindestlohn von 12 Euro pro Stunde
viele Firmen beklagen eine
Zusatzbelastung
und mit voller Wucht Hurrikan ihr sorgt
den South Carolina für Überschwemmungen
in Florida könnte der wieder Aufbau
Jahre dauern
[Musik]
nach der inszenierten Siegesfeier
gestern in Moskau eine deutliche
Niederlage für Kreml Chef Putin das
ukrainische Militär befreit eine weitere
strategisch wichtige Stadt die russische
Armee bestätigt den Rückzug aus Liman im
Norden der Region Donez die Truppe sei
wegen der Gefahr einer Einkesselung
abgezogen worden so das russische
Verteidigungsministerium mehr von Thomas
gonzio
der Schriftzug Liman Blau-Gelb die
Flagge Blau-Gelb der Soldat am
Stadteingang sagt die Mahn wird wieder
Ukrainisch
nicht weiter von eine andere Einheit
Gruppenbild in siegesstimmung
nach der völkerrechtswidrigen Annexion
von vier ukrainischen Regionen per
Federstrich im fernen Moskau vollzogen
und gefeiert nun also eine Niederlage
für den kremliman 120.000 Einwohner ist
isoliert und Moskau sagt man gebe die
strategisch wichtige Stadt auf
wegen des Risikos eingekesselt zu werden
haben wir die Truppen aus Liman
abgezogen
Kiew sagt dagegen ukrainische Truppen
hätten den Feind eingekesselt dort gut
5000 Russen festgesetzt was stimmt
unklar klar ist Lehman ist frei ebenso
wie der Weg bis direkt ran an das Gebiet
Lohans die einzige von großen komplett
besetzte Region auch aus kopiens mussten
sich Putins Truppen zurückziehen von
dort nun diese Bilder sie sollen das
Grauen erregende Ende einer Flucht
zeigen die Menschen in den Autos wollten
weg im Konvoi fliehen vor ständigem
russischen Beschuss doch bei russischen
Beschuss fanden sie gestern den Tod
zuvor waren schon im Süden Raketen auf
zivilistenfahrzeuge niedergegangen
Russland so jedenfalls scheint es
quittiert ukrainische Erfolge mit
Angriffen auf die schwächsten
wir gehen jetzt zum NATO Hauptquartier
nach Brüssel zu Ulf Röhler und nach Kiew
zu Tor geboote zunächst zu dir Torge wie
ist dieser militärische Erfolg der
Ukrainer in Liman einzuordnen
also zunächst einmal wir haben vor ca
einer Stunde Kontakt aufgenommen zum
ukrainischen Militär und da ist die
Sprachregelung so dass die russischen
Soldaten nach wie vor eingekesselt sind
und eben nicht abgezogen wurden 5000
sollen es ca sein ich wäre bei dieser
Zahl allerdings vorsichtig ich glaube
das lässt sich nicht seriös wirklich
einschätzen es ist aber wohl so dass
Liman eingenommen wurde zurückerobert
worden ist und das ist dann wirklich ein
strategisch wichtiger Erfolg weil es den
Weg öffnet Richtung Donbass hinein
Richtung nuhansk und dort weitere
Geländegewinne möglich macht und das
dürfte Moskau aus zwei Gründen so gar
nicht gefallen auf der einen Seite ist
es eine weitere militärische Niederlage
auf ukrainischem Gebiet und auf der
anderen Seite passt es so gar nicht ins
Bild was da Moskau gestern gezeichnet
hat nämlich das Bild einer glorreichen
Erweiterung der Russischen Föderation
mit dem was der heute passiert ist das
passt eben nicht zusammen
weiter nach Brüssel Ulf in in dieser
Situation fordern nun auch die Balken
eine NATO-Beitritt der Ukraine wie
fallen die Reaktion darauf aus
also das wird hier im NATO Hauptquartier
für Diskussion sorgen die Balken machen
Druck und wollen eben die Ukraine näher
an die NATO ranrücken gerade jetzt wo es
die militärischen Erfolge gibt aber ich
glaube am Ende wird es nicht zu einem
Beitritt und auch nicht zu
beschleunigten Verhandlungen kommen weil
wichtige Länder dagegen sind eben
Amerika zum Beispiel und auch
Deutschland der Grund ist ganz einfach
man hat Angst wenn die Ukraine näher an
der NATO dran ist oder sogar aufgenommen
wird dass man dann eben als NATO
Kriegspartei wird und dass wenn man
unbedingt vermeiden um eben Pute nicht
zu provozieren die NATO macht eine Tanz
eigentlich auf der rasierklinke auf
einer Seite sagt der
Nato-Generalsekretär immer dass man da
der Seite der Ukraine steht und dass die
einzelnen Ländern Waffen und Militär
Unterstützung liefern sollen auf der
anderen sagt man Seite sagt man immer
wieder man sei keine Kriegspartei ob
dieser Tanz auf der Rasierklinge am Ende
wirklich durchzuhalten ist ist sehr
schwierig zu sagen vor allem jetzt wo
der russische Präsident den trägt immer
weiter eskaliert danke nach Brüssel
ultra und danke nach Kiew zu Torge Bode
die Republik Moldau grenzt direkt an die
Ukraine bei einem Besuch dort hat
bundesverteidigungsministerin Lambrecht
dem Land mehr Unterstützung zugesagt
konkret geht es darum bei der Ausbildung
von Soldaten zu helfen und militärische
Ausrüstung zu liefern Moldau ist das
ärmste Land in Europa hat aber sehr
viele Kriegsflüchtlinge aus der Ukraine
aufgenommen
Polen hat schon vor dem Krieg versucht
unabhängiger von russischem Gas zu
werden und als dem Land im Frühjahr als
einem der ersten in Europa der Gashand
zugedreht wurde hatte Polen schon längst
andere Grundlagen gelegt vor allem mit
dieser baltik pipe sie ist 900 Kilometer
lang und ein Ableger von Europe 2 Gas
strömt seit heute von Norwegen über
Dänemark die Ostsee bis nach Polen für
das Land ein großer Schritt in Richtung
Energiesicherheit natürlich Steger
berichtet
was hier drin jetzt fließt gilt vielen
in Polen als Befreiungsschlag Gas direkt
aus Norwegen nach Polen nahe Stettin
wir können nicht nur unabhängig von
Russland den gasmix gestalten sondern
perspektivisch auch weiteren Ländern
helfen wie Tschechien oder der Slowakei
die ebenfalls ihren Mix von Russland
unabhängig machen wollen
mit der Pipeline könnte in der Zukunft
etwa die Hälfte des polnischen Gas
Jahresbedarfs gedeckt werden die Baltic
pipe vor 15 Jahren beschlossen diese
Woche eröffnet Polen wollte schon lange
vor dem ukraine-krieg Weg vom russischen
Gas hat Moskau immer misstraut
wir treten in eine neue Ära ein eine Ära
der Energie Souveränität Energie
Freiheit und verstärkten Energie
Sicherheit
allerdings nach den Attacken auf Nord
Stream 1 und 2 stellt sich gerade die
Frage der Sicherheit auch bei der
boardingpipe
solch eine Infrastruktur braucht ein
komplexes Abwehrsystem das aus einigen
Segmenten besteht vor allem ist
Spionageabwehr wichtig dazu auch die
Überwachung der Infrastruktur durch
Satelliten und Drohnen eine neue
Pipeline außerdem Ausbau des
lng-terminals in Swinemünde mit
internationalen Lieferungen Polen hat
sich früher als andere gekümmert um
Unabhängigkeit von russischem Gas
kommen wir jetzt zu einem immer wieder
auflodernden Konflikt mitten in Europa
vor 30 Jahren war der Krieg in Bosnien
Herzegowina für lange Zeit das
beherrschende Thema morgen gibt es
Wahlen in diesem politisch ziemlich
fragilen Staaten Gebilde aus bosnischen
Serben Kroaten und Muslimen Britta
Hilpert schildert die Ausgangslage und
wirft auch einen Blick auf die
bundeswehr-mission vor Ort
die Bundeswehr
ist ein Herzegowina in zablena im Süden
zeigen Oberstleutnant Roland B und Team
Präsenz ein weiteres ist dem serbisch
geprägten Norden sie suchen Kontakt
Gespräche das soll Spannungen mit
allein unsere Anwesenheit hat schon
einen psychologischen Effekt wir sind
nicht einfach nur irgendwelche
virtuellen gestalten wir sind wirklich
da und sind wirklich mit den Menschen im
Gespräch allein das stabilisiert
ungemein im Wahlkampf zündet besonders
Serbenführer miloradodic Muslime und
Christen könnten nicht zusammen leben
sagt er und fordert die Spaltung des
Landes Putin unterstützt ihn darin
US-Geheimdienste vermuten Geldflüsse und
Russland Freunde wie Ungarns Viktor
Orban machen Werbung für ihn
aber auch in anderen Volksgruppen setzen
Parteien auf Nationalismus statt sich um
echte Probleme zu kümmern meinen viele
Wähler wir ertrinken in Korruption und
Unrecht die Wahlen bringen uns nichts
sie kaufen unsere Stimmen lass sie das
ruhig hören aber nichts ändert sich
um sich zu ändern und zu einen brauche
das Land eine EU-Perspektive meint nicht
nur der hohe un-beauftragte Christian
Schmidt da wäre es gut wenn wir so wie
andere Länder Beitrittsverhandlungen
bekommen auch für Bosnien-Herzegowina
auch nach den Wahlen ist der Friede
prekär Wissen Roland B und sein Team und
ihre Präsenz allein wird ihn nicht
sichern können
zerstörte Existenzen Milliardenschäden
und mindestens 30 Todesopfer hinterließ
ihren in Florida danach wütet der
Wirbelsturm in den US-Bundesstaaten
South und North Carolina weiter der
Katastrophenschutz spricht von
hunderttausenden Stromausfällen und
schweren Überschwemmungen der
Wiederaufbau in den betroffenen Regionen
dürfte Monate und Jahre dauern Ulrike
rödle berichtet
es muss sehr schnell gegangen sein eine
knapp zwei Meter hohe Flutwelle trifft
die Stadtgarten City in South Carolina
die Welle überflutet Straßen und setzt
Häuser teilweise unter Wasser in vielen
Haushalten fällt der Strom aus auch
paulis Island eine kleine Stadt in South
Carolina wird von der Sturmflut
getroffen zuvor hatten Behörden die
Menschen gewarnt der Gouverneur von sask
Carolina wandte sich mit deutlichen
Worten an die Bevölkerung
noch gibt es keine Toten aber die Lage
bleibt lebensbedrohlich passen Sie also
auf sich auf seien Sie vorsichtig
in Florida wo Hurrican Ian vor vier
Tagen an Land getroffen war geht die
Suche nach Vermissten weiter es könnten
tausende sein mit Hubschraubern versucht
die amerikanische Küstenwache sich ein
Bild zu machen und hofft Menschen zu
retten
in vielen Gegenden steht das Wasser noch
immer Meter hoch
es ist für uns alle eine Katastrophe sie
hat uns alle gleichermaßen getroffen und
jetzt helfen wir uns untereinander so
gut es geht die Sturmschäden die
Hurrikan ihren verursacht hat sind
gewaltig es wird Monate wenn nicht Jahre
dauern alles wieder aufzubauen nun zieht
ihr als Tropensturm weiter Richtung
Norden
in Iran gehen die Proteste gegen die
Regierung weiter und in Deutschland
haben tausende Menschen ihre Solidarität
gezeigt in Frankfurt Hamburg und auch
Berlin forderten sie unter anderem ein
Ende des müller-regimes in Teheran und
mehr Selbstbestimmung für Frauen
Auslöser der Proteste war der Tod einer
jungen Iranerin die von der
Sittenpolizei in Teheran festgenommen
worden war und kurz darauf starb
zurück zu den heimischen sorgen jeder
zweite hier befürchtet Preisanstieg und
rekordinflation nicht bewältigen zu
können da dürfte vielen die neue
Anhebung des Mindestlohnes auf 12 Euro
pro Stunde gerade recht kommt seit heute
in Kraft profitieren davon mindestens 6
Millionen Menschen Stefan Schlösser über
Perspektiven und Erwartungen
rund 2200 Beschäftigte arbeiten für das
Wiesbadener Entsorgungsunternehmen
knetenbrech gordolig teilweise
zumindestlohn gestiegene Preise in jedem
Bereich insbesondere bei der Energie-
allgemeine Situation führt momentan zu
Kostensteigerungen die in Form von
Preisanpassungen leider an die Kunden
weitergegeben werden müssen deswegen
mussten wir jetzt auch schon
Preisanpassungen annehmen seit
Einführung 2015 ist der gesetzliche
Mindestlohn in mehreren Etappen
angestiegen zuletzt in kurzer Zeit um
rund 25 Prozent auf nunmehr 12 Euro 6
bis 8 Millionen Menschen bekommen für
ihre Arbeit bisher weniger pro Stunde
die Anhebung bringe ganze
Vergütungsstrukturen durcheinander
kritisieren Arbeitgeberverbände
vor allen Dingen muss man deutlich sehen
dass das eine große Auswirkung auch auf
die Tarife darüber hat denn wenn der
Einstieg für eine ungelernte Tätigkeit
bei 12 Euro liegt dann wird eine
gelernte Tätigkeit mit Berufserfahrung
dergleichen natürlich höher auch
entlohnt werden müssen insofern wird
sich das Ganze tarifgitter nach oben
verschieben
eine Entlassungswelle drohe aber nicht
sagen Arbeitsmarktforscher
die Studienlage zeigt deutlich dass im
cuger der Mindestlohn Einführung keine
Jobs verloren gegangen sind
das zeigen sich hingegen sehr positive
Effekte beispielsweise auf die
Stundenlöhne oder die Monatslöhne so ist
beispielsweise die Lohnungleichheit
signifikant zurückgegangen
an Entlassungen denkt man auch hier bei
knettenbrief goddelig nicht im Gegenteil
Fachkräfte werden dringend gesucht
ja nicht nur der Mindestlohn ändert sich
seit heute auch Minijobber dürfen mehr
verdienen und in Sachen Corona gibt es
neue Regeln können Sie alles sehr gerne
nachlesen bei ZDF heute bzw in unserer
App
morgen in einer Woche wählt
Niedersachsen einen neuen Landtag laut
jüngstem ZDF Politbarometer gibt es
einen Vorsprung für die SPD von
Ministerpräsident weil und in dieser
Zeit der mehrfachkrisen ist es vor allem
ein Thema das die Wähler umtreibt mehr
zur Stimmung vor der niedersachsenwahl
jetzt von Elisabeth Schmidt
Thorsten rowohld fühlt sich von der
Landespolitik im Stich gelassen vor zwei
Jahren hat er die Leitung der Herzer
zinkoxidwerke in Goslar übernommen auch
um Arbeitsplätze in der
strukturschwachen Region zu retten doch
jetzt drücken die hohen Energiepreise
denn das Unternehmen verbraucht 52
Millionen Kilowattstunden Gas im Jahr so
viel wie 5.200 Haushalte mit zwei
Personen für uns ist ganz klar dass wir
verplanungssicherheit eine
energiepreisbremse brauchen sowie beim
Gas als auch beim Strom damit wir
letztendlich auch wieder irgendwo planen
können auch die gegenüber unseren
Finanzinstituten
Existenzängste bei Unternehmen auf den
Einkaufsmeilen Sorge vor den
explodierenden Preisen gerade junge
Familien und Studierende wünschen sich
eine direkte Finanzspritze gerade beim
Einkaufen Pampers und teurer geworden
das Essen ist teurer geworden das ist
alles schwierig da würde man sich ein
bisschen Unterstützung wünschen dass man
vielleicht lieber einfach jedem 100 Euro
überweist und sagt okay das ist jetzt
für dich
kriegs- und Krisenzeiten Rücken vor den
Wahlen in Niedersachsen landespolitische
Themen in den Hintergrund einige
vermissen sie Schule Schule ganz klar
die Lehrer die Lehrerausbildung
Gleichberechtigung
Claudia kämpfert Energieexpertin und
gebürtige Niedersächsin hofft auf mehr
Weitsicht bald Zukunftsthemen im
selbsternannten Energieland Nummer 1 ich
würde mir wünschen dass man viel viel
stärker noch auf die erneuerbaren
Energien setzt da ist das Bundesland
schon sehr weit gerade was den Ausbau
der Windenergie angeht da geht aber noch
mehr woher der Wind im künftigen Landtag
weht entscheidet Niedersachsen in einer
Woche am 9 Oktober wird gewählt
wir sind beim Sport und Katja es gibt
viele enttäuschte Berliner ihr Verein
ihr Fußballverein hat zum ersten Mal
verloren so ist es Union Berlin geht
tatsächlich zum ersten Mal in dieser
Spielzeit als Verlierer vom Platz im
konkreten Fall vom Rasen der Eintracht
hier sind die Ergebnisse des 8
bundesligaspieltags Union verliert also
in Frankfurt 0:2 auch der BVB mit der
Niederlage zwei zu drei in Köln Leipzig
schlägt Bochum 4 zu 0 Freiburg Mainz 2:1
und auch ein Heimsieg in der Partie
Wolfsburg Stuttgart 3:2 das Abendspiel
zwischen Bremen und Gladbach ausführlich
im Aktuellen Sportstudio bereits gestern
Barrieren gegen Barriere 4:0 und kommen
wir zur Tabelle dort bleibt Union Berlin
trotzdem vorn dahinter jetzt Freiburg
und die Bayern und der BVB fällt von
zwei auf vier dann schon Eintracht
Frankfurt Leipzig klettert in die erste
Tabellenhälfte von 12 auf 9
dafür mindsets in der unteren Hälfte auf
10 Bremen kann am Abend Plätze gut
machen Wolfsburg verlässt einen
Abstiegsrang jetzt auf 13 und im Keller
dafür wieder Leverkusen und die
weitersieglosen Bochumer ja alles
Wichtige dieses Spieltags heute im
Aktuellen Sportstudio mit Studiogast
Timo Baumgartl von Union Berlin der
offen über seine Krebserkrankung spricht
los geht's um 23 Uhr
so Formel 1 morgen könnte Max Verstappen
erneut Weltmeister werden doch im
Qualifying zum Großen Preis von Singapur
wurde er nur Achter die Poleposition
holte sein erster wm-konkurrent Charlie
Clare
Charle erklärt den Moment des Erfolgs in
seiner Box niemand kann seine Bestzeit
schlagen noch ist die Hoffnung dabei
Ferrari Max Verstappen doch noch
abfangen zu können im Kampf um die WM
der Weltmeister im Red Bull auf seiner
letzten schnellen Runde die regengasse
Strecke trocknet immer weiter ab doch
dann biegt er in die Boxengasse ein nur
Startposition 8 fürs Rennen morgen der
Abbruch Befehl kam vom Kommandostand der
Grund Spritmangel Mick Schumacher
aufhang 13 Sebastian Vettel wird 14
und bei der volleyball-wm in den
Niederlanden und Polen hat das deutsche
Frauenteam im letzten Vorrundenspiel
eine 2:0 Satzführung noch aus der Hand
gegeben und zwei zu drei gegen Kanada
verloren
es geht so gut los Deutschland gewinnt
den Lodge die Sätze 1 und 2 mit 25 zu 12
und 26 zu 24 und führt auch im dritten
und vierten Satz aber die Kanadierinnen
geben nie auf drehen diese Rückstände
und erkämpfen sich im entscheidenden
fünften Satz ihren ersten Matchball nach
einem Ausschlag Fehler steht es 15:9 und
damit drei zu zwei für Kanada
Deutschland erreicht als Tabellen
vierter dennoch die zweite Gruppenphase
der WM die in drei Tagen beginnt
und findet da hoffentlich den Faden
wieder den sollen verlorener dann danke
für das sportabteil Katja morgen im
Süden viel Regen im Norden häufiger
sonnig mehr Wetter für den Feiertag dann
auch gleich mit Katja horneffer das
heute journal mit Christian Sievers
heute um 23 Uhr das war es von uns
schönen Samstagabend und bis morgen wenn
Sie mögen
[Musik]
guten Abend vom Ärmelkanal kommt morgen
schon gleich ein neues Tief
herangerauscht das ist das Tief Xenia
und das wird der Mitte und dem Süden
Deutschlands viel Regen bringen bevor
zum dritten Oktober dann das hochtimeo
übernimmt heute Nacht schüttet es noch
ergiebig am Alpenrand und über
Norddeutschland ziehen bei milden 13 bis
7 Grad weitere Regenschauer hinweg
Regenschauer vielleicht auch kurze
Gewitter gibt es auch morgen hier in
Norddeutschland bei einem West bis
Nordwestwind von der Eifel bis zum
Bayerischen Wald Dietz kräftigen Regen
und am Alpenrand schüttet es heftig
weiter jetzt über das Wochenende können
dort 60 bis 80 ordentlich sogar 100
Liter Regen pro Quadratmeter fallen ganz
anders sieht das am Oberrhein aus da
könnte sich morgen nämlich vorübergehend
auch mal kurz die Sonne zeigen und dann
klettern dort die Temperaturen ähnlich
wie am Niederrhein auf bis zu 20 Grad
sonst bleibt es im Dauerregen merklich
kühler bei 14 bis 17 Grad der dritte
Oktober das bringt uns dann ganz
freundliches Wetter der Dauerregen am
Alpenrand lässt nach und auch die
Regenschauer hier im Nordosten werden
immer weniger bei 13 bis 90 Grad ab
Dienstag deutet sich dann goldenes
Oktoberwetter an jedenfalls wenn sich
Nebel und Hochnebel am Morgen aufgelöst
haben schönes Wochenende